miles garrett has been chasing around
ben roethlisberger the steelers starter
and it's getting closer to official that
he will be the starter in 2021 after the
show ended yesterday and we spent some
time trying to figure out where all this
was heading
art rooney ii
issued a statement that
says a lot but doesn't say everything
here's what rooney had to say ben
roethlisberger and i met yesterday that
was tuesday morning we had a productive
meeting we were able to discuss a lot of
things that relate to where we are and
where we want to go ben assured me that
he is committed to coming back to help
us win and i told ben that we would like
to have him back to help us win a
championship
here is the key line we both understand
that the next step is to work out ben's
contract situation i'll say it again
chris yep
if it's just a matter of taking that 19
million he's due to make this year
and moving it around a little
abracadabra under the salary cap it's
not easy to do it could be done in less
than an hour
or or or less than that it could be done
in 15 minutes it's not hard you take the
19 million you convert 18.5
million of it to wait
18.925 million of it excuse me into a
signing bonus you reduce his salary to
the minimum of 1.075 that
18.925 gets spread over three four five
years
and it minimizes the additional amount
that gets put onto the 22.25 million
in past cap charges that will hit the
cap this year they're trying to land
between 22.25 and 41.25 it should not be
hard to figure that part of it out
unless the steelers wanted to take less
than 19 million that's the big question
that is yet to be resolved but i feel
like that's what the steelers have been
dancing around
and then
at the last possible minute they're
going to say oh by the way
we'd really like it if you'd take
15 14 right 13 whatever million less
than 19 million well i i mean
i would expect that to be the case at
some point that that will be the
conversation like you said i mean hey
i think they'll work out they're going
to work out the particulars you're right
it's not going to be that hard to do but
now they got to kind of get into the
nitty-gritty of the details and what is
what is ben willing to go out there and
play what is he willing to compromise on
the money situation you know i would
think at this point of his career where
he's at and we've talked about this a
lot with all the money he's made
um that he he's obviously realistic and
knows where the team is at in the salary
cap situation
it's more about legacy at this point
than anything i think for for a guy like
ben roethlisberger trying to get back to
a super bowl maybe win a third one that
puts you in a special class of
quarterbacks certainly so
i would expect i i i mean i don't know
mike my gut says i think he's gonna he's
gonna you know bow down to those needs
he might go south of 18. maybe he'll get
down into 10 to 12 million dollars he's
made a ton of money and they're
certainly
hey they're certainly taking a chance i
don't want to say a chance but they're
taking a chance on an older quarterback
who didn't play great towards the end of
the year as we know but also you know
there's not many other options out there
for them as we sit here right now either
so uh i'll be interested to see where it
goes but i do expect them to take that
take that big time pay cut
i i don't know that i do or that i don't
all i know is at this point it hadn't
well i don't know as of today as of
yesterday as and more accurately as of
tuesday late afternoon early evening the
steelers to my understanding had not yet
broached the possibility of taking less
than 19 that it was always about being
creative to but you don't it's there's
no creativity involved we know the
formula you take the money he's going to
make you reduce it to the minimum and
you convert the rest of it to a bonus
that gets spread over multiple years
they've been doing that ever since a
salary cap has been in existence that's
why teams get themselves into cap
trouble because they deal with
short-term cap issues by kicking dollars
into future years with that device and
then the reckoning comes later that's
why they're facing 22.25 million under
ben roethlisberger's name this year even
if he's not on the team i mean that that
charge is
is
there it's permanent it's not getting
changed it's not getting moved they're
not going to get his
his cap number below that the question
is how close to that can they get and
think of it this way
if ben roethlisberger
were due to become a free agent march 17
yeah given the salary cap dropping down
to 182 183
is anybody paying him 19 million
for this year on a one-year deal anybody
gonna pay him 19 million i i i yeah
that's major iffy you're right i don't
know if there's going to be a lot of
suitors out there you're right now the
way he looked at the end of the year we
know the injury history he's been banged
up we know that you know or at least we
think we know about the knee issues you
certainly could see it on film as we
discussed earlier in the week about this
conversation there was a difference and
i do believe he was injured because
early in the year there was more bounce
and movement in the pocket as the year
went on and you thought wait is he hurt
we were hearing some of those rumors
about the knee and all that it became
more stagnant and you know less movement
with his feet in the pocket so no i
think you're right mike it's different
than philip rivers or tom brady last
year there's there's a little bit more
of a risk with ben roethlisberger
attached to him and i don't know if
there would be that kind of market for
him out there
and i think that's yeah that's that's
part of this because
you can't do the lifetime achievement
award contract now not with the cap
going down and you can't pay him for
anything he's ever done in the past it
can only be
what will you do for me this year what
can i expect this year what would the
market for your services be
this year and i think that's a fair
question if the steelers
and ryan toner remember roethlisberger's
agent are going to be communicating
about this
you know is it is it fair i don't know
but i i sure would raise that point hey
uh ben's due to make 19 million from us
this year we don't think anybody else
would pay him 19 million you're free to
go see if anyone would
but
we think that that what he gets this
year should be more in line with the
market
for his services and remember it was ben
roethlisberger who said back when this
all first bubbled up a few weeks ago i
don't care how much i get paid this year
okay you don't how about 1.075 million
well how about let's how about let's
just how about let's just create
18.925 million in cap space by dropping
you all the way to the minimum for this
year with no
funny business with no
movement of money just just a straight
drop from 19 to the minimum let's do
that if you don't care so i i think
that's why it hasn't been done because
it would be easy to do the restructuring
that still gives him 19 million it's
harder to do the restructuring that
gives him less because the first thing
you got to do is figure out what that
less is going to be right well and i
think your your point's real i don't
think it's um
again i i don't think they're gonna be
able to shop him out in the market right
now and you look at the teams that have
quarterback situations
none of them scream ooh
this this is a spot for
we got a ready team and we need a guy
who's been there done that
and we want a guy like ben
roethlisberger no none of those
situations scream that to me so that i
don't think there is a market out there
and you know listen you could certainly
sit here and argue
that the last contract or the contract
he's on currently
was very generous of the pittsburgh
steelers to big ben i mean that contract
in itself is a little bit of like hey
you know you're still good but it's also
a little icing on top and some sprinkles
and everything else because of things
you did in all the other years leading
up to this i felt like that was a little
bit of a gift in itself that way as far
as that contract is concerned but
you know again i can speak for myself
uh i
i would take a significant pay cut if i
was in a situation like big ben
roethlisberger significant i don't know
you know where he finds the line of
respect or disrespect does he still want
to just you know be in the 10 million
dollar range just to say hey like i am
out here throwing touchdown passes and
doing some things and i'd like to have a
little bit you know money coming my way
and and protection for the year of or
what i'm doing but hey they gotta they
got does he want bud dupree on the team
next year does he wanna does he want
juju smith schuster back you know those
are the type of things depending on how
much he's willing to take less
certainly increases their chances to
sign back those guys and especially a
guy like bud dupree where you know we we
would we would say him and tj watt was
the best pass rush combination in
football before they got hurt last year
they gave ben a two-year extension in
2019 with a
37.5 million dollar signing bonus right
34 million dollar average salary on the
extension and again a package of 19
million this year because some people
would look at that and say boy 19
million that's not much he's made his
money on this deal previously and in the
year that he got the the signing bonus
of thirty seven and a half million he
appeared in two games and i think that's
part of this too
what what risk
as the steelers given the possibility
that that he's gonna break down he turns
39 next week but chris there was a clue
in art rooney's statement that
reinforces what you and i were saying
yesterday that the steelers are far
enough removed from the way things went
poorly at the end of the season to start
feeling confident about the next season
because what rooney said is
i would i told ben that we would like to
have him back to help us win a
championship right they think they can
win they do a championship they've come
to the conclusion because i think as of
last week kevin colbert the gym of the
team was kind of like well we're really
not sure what we're going to have around
him and i think from their perspective
it was if we're not going to really be
in a position to go grab the brass ring
why do we want to continue this
relationship they have since decided
they think they're going to be in a
position to grab the brass ring i don't
a lot of things can happen sure i mean
they're they're at least in the in the
mix they are and the injuries can happen
to other teams too which make it easier
for you to grab the brass ring but that
that
it's it's i still think we get to
october november december there's going
to be mutual regret that they did that
one last year uh especially if ben takes
less money
and and ends up being a little bit
resentful like he feels like i have no
choice but to take less money well
because they kind of backed me into a
corner here he may get a little pissy
sorry london about that and i still
think there's a chance neither side
wants to be the villain and they both
are kind of interested in ending this i
still think that's hovering over this
situation to some degree i i i mean i
uh maybe a a little bit there i'm not
going to totally disagree with that but
i think they're in a they're in a corner
a little bit about where their team is
at you know they have a super bowl
defense and then
you know the offense i think they could
probably look at it and go wait wide
receivers are great okay quarterback is
old and you know a little crickety and
whatever else but still
you know
you agree i don't know you know what i
mean
but rickety yeah rickety cricketing
one of those right jiminy crickety yeah
exactly that's right i think that sort
of was in my head there um but that i
think they also look like you said
evaluate their team and they go ma'am
you know big ben still made a number of
really good high level throws during the
year
and we didn't do him justice and they
probably look at some of their fixes and
go okay i mean it's not crazy to think
we can't get this offensive line with a
new offensive coordinator and get two
you know two new pieces on the offensive
line and maybe you know resign alejandro
villanueva back on the team and they go
no we're we're closer to the top and in
the bottom so i think that that's
probably what they come to as far as the
realization is that and and then the
other thing mike too
like
so what shove them in a corner
like like
what do we get like let's stop this
first off at his age right now he's not
as good as tom brady right tom brady
took 25 million dollars last year and
you and i both know and most people in
football know this that have been around
the league new england shoved tom brady
in the corner a bunch
and he wasn't you know
old and crickety like big ben was at
that time you know back in 2012 and 13
and 14 those years when you know brady
was taking less it wasn't like he was
raising his hand and going hey i want to
take less
i want to take less money no they were
kind of like you haven't played all that
great those last few years you're going
to get this do you want to roll the dice
and go somewhere else and brady went no
i don't i'll stay here and then of
course he improved his game and then he
regained the power because he was like
no i'm pretty good still now what do you
want to do but
what's wrong with force like it's gotten
lost in this era of football you know
when i when i was growing up
quarterbacks got forced in the corner
all the time i i don't know where that
happened or that disconnect and i don't
think there's anything wrong with that
for a team to do it
these are just i think some of the
natural
aches and pains that relate to
the ultimate separation from a long-term
franchise quarterback and i think that
that the steelers are walking on
eggshells a little bit here just a
little bit and i think ben is saying all
the right things too because at the end
of the day
there's a fan base that's caught in the
middle sure he's paying very close
attention to what's happening here and i
really do think that's that's part of it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports